uh
[Music]
the cleaners originated as the blue
collar workers of new york city
janitors sanitation garbagemen
electricians construction workers truck
drivers
these are the people that the government
originally asked to assist in saving the
city through transport digging of mass
graves and eventually the construction
of the wall that would surround the
quarantine zone
these are the groups that continue to
support the civil services when the city
infrastructure was breaking down
unfortunately these are also some of the
people who were left behind when the jtf
and the government pulled out of the
dark zone
and much like the first wave of division
agents these men and women were left
feeling betrayed and abandoned
it was at this point that an individual
by the name of joe farrow stepped up and
organized these abandoned workers into a
force that would do what was needed to
contain the virus and restore order to
the streets of new york city
before the outbreak joe ferro lived and
worked in manhattan with his wife as a
sanitation worker
he was a family-oriented man a devout
husband and he cared deeply for his
niece
farah was always particularly vocal
about his opinions and frequently called
into live radio broadcasts to share his
point of view with the american public
when the dollar flu outbreak first hit
his wife was one of the first victims to
become infected and shortly after he
succumbed to the virus
after this his mindset towards the
country and the government started to
shift
he calls into a radio broadcaster
sounds like we have an old time on the
line joseph farrell
hey joe what's your take on the dollar
flu i think this really shows how
vulnerable this country is
i mean how stupid you have to be not to
go to the hospital when you're sick as a
dog
we got people going to work to the
supermarket even to the goddamn movies
infecting thousands of other people out
of pure ignorance i'm telling you this
is going to blow up big time just
because most people are too damn stupid
to realize what's going on there's no
one with the balls not the government
not nobody and the brains to do what's
got to be done to keep this from
spreading sorry to cut you off there joe
thanks as always for your thoughts
as more and more people started to get
infected and more and more bodies
started lining the streets
vera's mental state continued to slide
with his wife now dead he continues to
think that the government isn't doing
anything to stop the virus
his thoughts is that no one is brave
enough to do anything about it
with all of his faith in the government
now lost he takes matters into his own
hands
he assembles the men and women who
worked alongside the jtf from the
government before they left
this is not rocket science
you don't need a degree from some fancy
college to understand exactly what's
going on here
this virus is going to continue to
spread as long as there are infected
people walking around
now you can put up all the fences and
checkpoints you want but that's not
going to stop a virus
you want to kill it
you have to burn it
destroy it completely and before it can
spread
now
we have the equipment we need to take
care of this and the guts to do what
nobody else has a sack to
it's not going to be easy
and they're not going to understand
we're doing this for the greater good
but when it's over
and we've stopped this thing right here
they'll thank us
he proceeded to tell them that there is
only one way to stop the virus
burn it
burn all of it
burn every trace of it
and thus
the cleaners were born
unlike the other factions the cleaners
are assembled with the intentions of
doing good
vera strongly believes that they are the
true heroes fighting against the virus
on the front lines
he could be heard stating that they're
the ones leaving everything they had
behind just so they can stay in new york
and do what has to be done
i'm telling you
what i'm seeing here
are the bravest men and women i've ever
seen in my life
and we've all lost someone
but you're still willing to stand up and
hear me out and i've got one simple
thing to tell you one truth that the
government refuses to recognize
the sick are already dead
the moment they get infected they got a
death sentence
the only thing they can do from there is
spread the disease further that's why
we're standing here today without our
families without our children
because we understand what it's going to
cost to save this city and this country
and we're willing to pay that price
nobody else will and people will die
because of that but you all the ones
making the hard choices right now
you ask me
you're all goddamn heroes
because of his wife vera has seen what
the virus can do firsthand
and he is convinced that there is no
saving people once they're infected
given that the government has fled the
quarantine zone he decides that it's up
to him and the cleaners to stop the
virus and get back control of the city
and that there is no one else brave
enough to take the necessary steps to
stop this thing once and for all
not only was he convinced that they're
the good guys but he continues to
convince others too
his followers hold a lot of respect for
him because of his commitment and
dedication to his goals that he isn't
afraid of jumping into the front lines
and getting his hands dirty
you gotta give it to pharaoh when he
says he wants something done he gets it
done what i like is that he's out here
doing it with us
i had to shop boss once he never left
the freaking office
pharaoh
he's out on the streets yeah he gets his
hands dirty never ask the guy to do what
he won't do himself ain't that the truth
he got himself a little bit of a temple
though you got to watch that
he just pissed really easy if you
question the mission yeah i guess you
could say he's kind of a
hot head
you get it you see what i did there
that screw you i thought it was funny
through pharaoh's guidance the cleanest
weapon of choice is fire
fire is the ultimate cleaning tool
so everything that comes in contact with
the virus must burn
from parts and pieces they find lying
around they create this signature weapon
the flamethrower
they've also developed a recipe for
napalm and their own hazmat suits
their goal to purify the city by burning
away impurities and corruption
the cleaners are devoted to the job and
if anyone gets in their way they're a
part of the problem and swiftly doubt
too
they travel from area to area cleaning
streets
if there is any evidence of
contamination they won't hesitate
setting ablaze cars or even buildings
full of people
as in their eyes the sick are already
dead and they're doing humanity a favor
by stopping the spread of the virus
however there were a couple of problems
with this method of purifying and
cleansing of the virus
firstly the cleaners can't really tell
if people were infected
they aren't doctors they're just looking
for the smallest thing that could be a
sign
feeling a little run down and showing
signs of fatigue too bad better safe
than sorry
and secondly as jtf neurologist jessica
kendall mentions
their methods are actually making the
situation far worse from a neurologist's
point of view
the goal of wiping out the virus by
burning everything in sight actually
severely hinders any effects towards
creating a vaccine to help keep it from
spreading
while out on a foraging mission a group
of cleaners found a trap division agent
called vivian conley and proceeded to
take her back to joe ferro
already flagged as rogue at this point
she was interested in seeing what
pharaoh had to say
before long she found herself amongst a
group of ex-sanitation workers and
contractors and these guys were taking
matters into their own hands
like herself they too were feeling the
pain of loss and abandonment of the jtf
left them behind
conley took comfort with these people
and their plans to eradicate the virus
so not long after meeting them she
joined their ranks
immediately she went to work putting her
previous experience as a chemical
engineer to use
she started upgrading their weapon
systems and training them in the basics
of military combat
the cleaners quickly accepted her
guidance and had already begun talking
about her as a potential successor to
joe ferro one day
you know i've been thinking
i don't like the sound of that with viv
having our backs like this and her
reworking our entire refinery process
do we still need joe don't [ __ ] say
that i know i know he started the whole
movement and he's taking care of us but
ever since vivian came on i feel like
joe's doing less and she's the one
actually steering the ship she's an
asset yeah but there's no question she
also answers to joe we all do so shut
your [ __ ] mouth and fall in line oh
of course i didn't mean nothing by it
but you know
joe's not gonna be around forever
he will need someone to fill his shoes
the way i see it
connolly's our best choice
right
obviously
but not another bad word about joe or
i'll throw you into the fire
vivian conley possessed an impressive
resume much of which placed her quickly
in the sights of the shd recruiters
as a chemical engineer she had learned
how to develop and design chemical
manufacturing processes
another valuable set of skills included
her work as a counter-terrorism agent
where she incorporated military tactics
techniques and strategy to neutralize
terrorists and their organizations
however not everyone was convinced she
was the right fit for the role as a
division agent
tendencies for fixation and obsession
well that's exactly what we want in an
agent someone who gets obsessed with a
target and goes after them regardless of
the collateral or she will just commit
to the mission fixation and obsession
can be a good thing you just like her
because she's a techie hey we need
people who are willing to think outside
of the box and we need more people that
can fix our [ __ ] when it breaks she's
resourceful and obsessive the program
will guide her in the right direction
and give her the right focus she's smart
capable and [ __ ] brilliant we can't
depend on continuous training for these
people to qualify
we need to have a standard from the
get-go what if they're activated
tomorrow would you be comfortable having
conley out there
i would no question all right
i'll put her on for the next phase
during conley's psych evaluation a
number of concerns were highlighted in
regards to her extreme obsessive
behaviors which could have the potential
to cause a number of problems while out
in the field
but like so many before her she was
pushed through regardless of the fears
and given the go-ahead to progress to
the next stage of recruitment
not long after the green poison outbreak
conley was activated as a first wave
agent and deployed into midtown
manhattan to assist the jtf in securing
the quarantine zone
shortly after activation the joint task
force was ordered to stop and move out
of the area leaving conley and the other
division agents to complete the
assignment on their own
as the agents struggled with the
seemingly impossible task eventually a
number of them were killed by the
growing hostile presence while others
succumbed to the virus itself
and those who survived were forced to
retreat
hey connolly keener
you're so alive thanks to your turret
can you believe the jtf would turn on us
like that i believe weak people will
always make bad choices when they're
scared and we'll have to pick up the
slack
you want some help not on this one
you'll only get in my way
comes with the territory i'm gonna take
care of this
fortunately for conley she was one of
the few that managed to get away
however sadly for her she was about to
find out that her own family had just
become some of the latest victims of the
dollar flu
mad with grief conley needed someone to
blame
someone needed to pay for this
incompetence and mishandling of the
crisis
she decided to focus her anger solely on
the government and the obedient jtf
soldiers who blindly followed their
orders
but eventually even she would be caught
up in the chaos
and found herself in the middle of a hot
zone that resulted in her becoming
trapped under a pile of rubble caused by
an explosion from a nearby building
we got a live one over here they look
infected
nope might be jtf though try again riker
check the watch
she's division
not anymore
right she's one of those
red ring and all hey let's bring her in
joe will want to talk to her hey don't
try anything now i'm just gonna take
that little gun of yours be my guest
i can't wait to see this joe of yours
the second wave division agents first
encountered the cleaners in an
underground subway network
the cleaners were tasked with purifying
the area by burning everything and
everyone in there
although their goal was to retrieve paul
roads the division agents stopped the
cleaners from achieving their task and
quickly eliminated them from the site
the cleaners then attacked the hudson
refugee camp
but again the division agents and the
jtf managed to stop them before the
entire site was put up in flames
from the information gathered the
division identified the source of the
virus was able's department store
the agent set forth to gather some
samples of the original infected dollar
bills
but the cleaners were already there
setting the entire mall ablaze
but yet again the superior training and
equipment of the shd agents pushed the
cleaners back and were able to secure
the samples
it was at this point that the division
realized that the hostile faction known
as the cleaners were far more organized
than originally thought and they weren't
going anywhere
they needed to be dealt with
after the jtf had discovered the cleaner
headquarters and that this was also
their source of napalm production the
division agents were sent in to shut
them down as well as putting a stop to
the napalm production
the agents also found joe ferro himself
after a small conflict
the leader of the cleaners was
eventually killed by the division agents
with the source of the napalm destroyed
and their leader assassinated the
cleaners were demoralized
but regardless the cleaners continue to
push on believing deeply in the goals of
doing what no one else has the guts to
do
they went on to build their own super
weapon the dragon
a fire truck a literal fire truck with
an enormous flamethrower and mortar
attached
this was to be used to clear out large
areas and buildings more efficiently
allowing them to cover more ground
although well defended this too was
intercepted by the division agents
before it was ever able to be unleashed
into manhattan
upon fira's death conley took over as
his successor and quickly regrouped her
scattered forces
from there she began the restructure and
reorganization into a group of
individuals that would eventually become
even more deadly than before
because of the division the cleaners had
taken a heavy hit
along with killing their leader the one
who started it all their resources and
fuel had also taken a hit and were
running incredibly low
but conley had foreseen this and had
already scouted ahead to find the ideal
solution to their problems
we need more fuel at this rate we're
gonna run out in a few weeks we've been
draining every deposit in midtown but
we're going to use it all eventually in
midtown yes
we're going to have to migrate and
abandon everything we've built
there's a stranded oil tanker on the
lower east side it crashed into two
bridges during the hurricane with oil in
it enough to last at least eight months
a year for smart that's unbelievable
went down there myself the crew is still
on board but we can take care of that
no one else has claimed it yet should be
a cakewalk put a stripe team together
we'll head down there tonight and take
care of the crew
once the site's secured i'll give a
green light for backup then we'll have a
refinery up and running in a few days
yes ma'am
conley made the call to relocate the
cleaners operation down to south
manhattan
there they could set up shop and begin
rebuilding their ranks
her scouts soon found an abandoned cargo
ship on the shore and conley set the
task of taking over the ship and setting
it up as a refinery in order to feed the
heavy need of fuel for the upcoming
battles
conley's successes soon caught up with
her
someone she hadn't seen since the jtf
first pulled out of the quarantine zone
came knocking
some friends you've made
what are you doing here checking in on
you
you seem to be doing okay more than okay
these guys have their priorities
straight
this [ __ ] isn't going to be sorted out
unless we take full measures oh they're
very principled and
uncompromising i'll give you that what
do you want tina
look you need to think bigger the
cleaners aren't going to solve this on
their own you need help
leverage and that would be you and some
friends
i'm putting together something special
we are going to save this city no matter
the cost free from disease and
corruption
take down the jtf and the division for
good and where do we fit into that well
for starters
are you familiar with a man named vitali
chernenko
rogue agent aaron keener came to conley
offering a partnership
while hesitant to work with kina her
blind rage towards the dollar flu and
the promise of information on the
location of one of the people who were
responsible for it vitaly trinenko was
enough to convince her to join his side
kena would later request that conley
bring on fellow rogue agent javier
kajika
she wasn't interested
she had heard of kajika and what he'd
been up to and didn't want the cleaners
to be a part of it
but kina told her of his mission and
that kajika could assist in removing the
jtf
who at this stage were the only thing
standing between the cleaners and their
goal
conley reluctantly agreed
keena provided conley with details of
where tranco was being held
he informed her that the lmb had been
holding him and had handed him over to
the black tusk after joining their
ranks conley ordered the cleaners to
assault the black task on coney island
taken by surprise and heavily
outnumbered the black tasks were quickly
eliminated
however unknown to the cleaners the shd
had also found out about trinico's
location
and while the cleaners and black tusks
were preoccupied with fighting each
other they quickly moved in and
extracted the russian scientists
rogue agents cleared out the jtf guards
conley was sent by kina to set up his
new weaponized virus charges in certain
areas of city hall
the damage was extensive
division agents from washington dc
arrived in new york to investigate the
attack
where they quickly found out that conley
and the other rogue agents were
responsible for the attack and that they
were operating under aaron kina's
guidance
local peacekeepers were able to provide
intel on conley's whereabouts and from
there the division agents were able to
locate the cleaners who were assaulting
an apartment building with conley being
present
however before the agents could tear
through the cleaners conley had escaped
through intel found within the building
the agents were able to pinpoint where
conley had been residing
she was holding out in an abandoned
cargo ship on the shore of south
manhattan
the agents assaulted the cargo ship
head-on and were met by a large group of
cleaners
battling floor by floor the agents
eventually made their way to the top
deck
and after flushing her out by reversing
the gas pipes they faced her head-on
after a short encounter the agents
managed to take her down
but connolly had one last surprise
as she dropped to the ground screaming
the set of explosives she had strapped
to her body
detonated
she had no intentions of being taken
alive
the cleaners were assembled in an
attempt to save new york city
unfortunately the misguided methods had
them set on a more brutal genocidal path
while they were originally brought
together by a grief-stricken husband who
saw them as the misunderstood heroes of
the dramatic events that were unfolding
after his death they continued on their
mission under the leadership of a former
division agent who was being manipulated
by aaron kina who had much larger plans
for revenge against the government
after kina's death in the defeat of
conley the cleaners have now scattered
into smaller groups
although their threat seems to have been
considerably reduced any remaining
cleaners at this point still seem very
much committed to fera's goal of burning
out the virus and anyone who stands in
their way
the cleaners are by far my favorite
faction in the division universe so far
i've been wanting to put this video
together for a while the cleanest story
has been spread across multiple videos
up until now so i wanted it summed up
into a single location
i have a few others to get through as
well so expect to see a few more summary
videos on some of the other groups and
characters
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one
cheers uncle joe is that you yeah
sweetheart it's me how are you kiddo i'm
good mommy and daddy feeling okay yeah
but we've been sitting at home for days
uncle joe it's boring i bet it is kiddo
hey listen
i want to tell you something
you know how sometimes uncle joe is on
the radio yeah well it might be that
i'll be on the radio again soon
or the people will talk about me there
and they might say things that aren't
true okay
well whatever they may say
i want you to know
i want you to remember that
that i only ever wanted you to be safe
everything i'm doing all the good and
bad
is so you could be safe
okay okay
that's my girl
gotta go now
i love you
[Applause]
[Music]